وقع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما
يعتمد النسخه المحدثه من عقيده السياسه
الخارجيه الروسيه وجاء في العقيده ان
مخاطر الصدام تتنام بين الدول الكبرى بما
فيها الدول النوويه وان احتمال الانتقال
الى حرب كبرى يزداد كما تشير الى ان موسكو
مهتمه بضمان التوازن الاستراتيجي وتعايش
السلمي مع الولايات المتحده من جهه قال
وزير الخارجيه
روسيسكو تنظر في انشاء نظام عالمي جديد
سيكون اساسا لجميع العلاقات الدوليه واضاف
ان استخدام القوات المسلحه ضد من ينفذ
هجمات على روسيا سيكون ضمن التعديلات على
عقيده السياسه الخارجيه واكد ان لدى روسيا
فرصا لتطوير العلاقات الاستراتيجيه مع
الصين والهند واسيان والعالم الاسلامي
وامريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا بينما ستنظر
موسكو في امكانيه اتخاذ اجراءات متناسبه
مع اعمال الدول غير الصديقه